[موسيقى]
مشروع هارب الذي يشغل العالم حاليا هو
برنامج ابحاث الشفق القطبي النشط عالي
التردد التابع لسلاح الجو الامريكي تم
اغلاقه عام 2015 وتحويله الى جامعه الاسكا
يحتوي على 180 هوائيا موزعه على مساحه 14
هكتارا تنبعث منها موجات لاسلكيه عاليه
التردد تصل الى الغلاف الجوي للارض
وتحديدا طبقه الايون سبار التي تحتوي على
الغاز الايوني ولكن بنسبه قليله جدا ومهمه
هذا المشروع دراسه كيفيه زياده كثافه
الغاز المذكور وتاثيره على الغلاف الجوي
وسحب البلازما متعدده الالوان المعروفه
باسم الشفق القطبي
الزلازل الطبيعيه جدا وسهله المناقشه واي
تفسير خارج ذلك هو تعقيد غير مبرر الزلازل
ليست السبب وراء العدد الكبير من الخسائر
التي شاهدناها في سوريا وتركيا بل ببساطه
المباني المشيده سيئه التصميم كانت السبب
وراء كل هذا الدمار
[موسيقى]
البشر يستطيعون افتعال زلزال ولكن ذو قدره
بسيطه جدا ولا تتعدى قوته الدرجه الواحده
عبر طريقه واحده وهي ضخ نسبه معينه من
المياه في قشره رقيقه من الصخور